nous sommes à communaux un écart de
Sainte-Suzanne ou activités agricole et
développement urbains sont en harmonie
entre les cannes et les bananiers
quelques maisons toutes neuves émergent
du chemin du haut
mais que reste-t-il du souvenir de Dioré
je sais pas ce qui était mais je n'ai
pas tellement
l'histoire et tout ça
est né à La Rochelle vers 1686 promu
capitaine au régiment de la tour il se
marie à La Rochelle à Henriette Jupin de
fonds d'aumières dont il aura 7 enfants
réformé de son corps il reçoit en
décembre 1728 une commission du
lieutenant du roi pour la lointaine et
le bourbon
il arrive dans l'île en septembre 1724 à
bord de la Vierge de Grasse avec son
épouse et son beau-frère Jacques Jupin
de fond de miel qui lui servira de
secrétaire en effet Diori et ne doit sa
promotion qu'à la protection du
directeur mouchard
de son court séjour il ne restera que
peu de bons souvenirs leur est à la
crise du café avec une chute des cours
et une production excédentaire difficile
à écouler de 8 sous la livre en 1722 le
cours dégringole à 5 sous en 1738
son nom est également associé au
dépeuplements de Bourbon pour coloniser
l'Isère l'Île-de-France ne compte en
effet à l'époque quelques employés de la
compagnie et des soldats il lui incombe
donc de fournir des femmes et de vanter
les atouts de l'Isère afin d'y impulser
la colonisation
il quitte Bourbon en 1727 et prend
ensuite la place du chevalier d'oignon à
l'Île-de-France et ses cycles de
Fontbrune qui le remplacent à Bourbon
son œuvre aura essentiellement consisté
au développement du quartier de
Sainte-Suzanne il meurt en 1741